Film Courage: How do you train someone to
believe that their success is inevitable?
Erica Wernick, Author/Success Coach: I drill
it in them a hundred times until we believe
it.
I think that whenever you're trying to take
on a new belief sometimes our subconscious
mind needs proof and so I try to tell people
what that means in tangible terms like why
is your success inevitable and what will happen
if you don't believe your success is inevitable,
right?
If you don't believe your success is inevitable
it is very likely that you have a plan b that
you have some sort of backup plan that you
have set up a timeline for yourself where
if this doesn't happen in five years I'm going
move back home or I'm going to do something
else, right?
You're coming up with insurance because you
don't believe 100% (it's like a prenup for
your dream) because you don't believe 100%
that it's going to work out and what happens
is that when you don't believe your success
is inevitable you don't take the big risks
you don't put yourself out there in the same
way because you don't believe that it can
happen right so it really impacts the strategy
or the actions that you end up taking so I
try to help people by showing them where you
know where their current belief of not believing
their success is inevitable is leading them
and how that's playing out and I like to inspire
people to show them like why I think their
success is inevitable and I think that if
you can take away the lottery feel of succeeding
right because I think that you'll hear often
oh succeeding in Hollywood that's like winning
the lottery so for example one of my clients
I think this is in my book she said that that
was something that she had heard a lot you
know that good luck trying to make it in Hollywood
that's like winning the lottery and so I said
to her can you count on your hand can you
name any people you know who have won the
lottery and she was like you know I don't
think I know anyone who's won the lottery
I said okay now can you count on your hand
and name me people who have succeeded in Hollywood
and she listed like 10 people that she personally
knew who were doing well in the industry and
so you know because we want to give our subconscious
brain the subconscious part of our mind some
sort of tangible proof to hold on to and so
when we go through that it's like oh okay
so it's actually not as hard as winning the
lottery it's not that random because I i can
name so many more people that have succeeded
right so suddenly your subconscious goes oh
okay that's different so we start looking
for proof of why like why is your success
inevitable like why is it inevitable that
you will succeed well if you take a look at
you know all the people who are successful
and who are you know if we take a look at
their actions or everything that they've done
and if you're doing the same things it is
inevitable that it will lead to success and
that success might look different to every
person and however you define success but
you know I really try to help people retrain
their brain to understand that succeeding
in Hollywood doesn't have to be this insane
unlikely thing you know I think that we kind
of come into it with that notion and so we
want to train our brain to understand that
that's not actually true do you think some
people might want to fail because it brings
more sympathy more people like you if too
successful people won't like you I that's
an interesting question i've never thought
of it that way I think a lot of people want
to fail because if their subconscious mind
does not believe that they can succeed if
they fail they're proving it right and people
like to be right so they like to say see told
you I couldn't succeed right and so like I
always used to give this example sorry I'm
giving so many actor examples I work with
a lot of actors butyou know if you don't believe
that you 100 are going to succeed as an actor
you might take a day job that is a nine to
five and if you have a nine to five day job
you can't really audition I guess now it's
a little different during the pandemic with
self tapes everything self tapes right now
but you know pre pandemic and hopefully post
pandemic auditions will be in person again
and they're going to be during the day during
the week right and so if you have a nine to
five job you're taking this on because you
think you're doing the responsible thing and
we could talk about day jobs is like a whole
other conversation where we can have where
a lot of people have an idea in their mind
that the only way to financially support themselves
is through nine to five workbut that's like
a self-sabotaging move right and so then you're
not getting auditions because you can't go
on them unless you're calling out for a doctor's
appointment every day and then you end up
you know a couple years in and you're not
succeeding in Hollywood and then you can go
see I was right I'm not succeeding in this
town in this industry so I think thatpeople
self-sabotage just to like prove their subconscious
mind rightbut there's there's so many reasons
why people want to fail that some people are
afraid of success they're afraid you know
kind of what you're talking about are they
afraid of like not being liked but also what
does that mean in the dynamics of your family
you know what will your family think if you
succeed what does that look likeyou know how
will you feel if you're quote unquote more
successful than your parents or you know someone
that raised you or something you know people
struggle with so many nuanced things about
failing and succeeding so I think there are
many reasons but those are a few right or
or maybe ifthe the brother or the sister was
always the golden child and then the black
sheep actually surpasses it yes that that's
a taboo no it's not okay yeah there's that's
interesting people will be afraid of success
like that because we would think oh no no
that will not I'm that wouldn't happen to
me no I just you know yeah and some people
think that if I do succeed there are other
things in life I won't be able to have you
know like if I'm successful in hollywood I
won't be able to havea happy marriage and
raise kids you know people have that fear
sometimes of like you know the scheduling
with hollywood that I won't be able to have
a family things like that so sometimes people
self-sabotage because they're afraid that
even if they do succeed there are other things
that they won't be able to have or that it'll
you know negatively impact relationships that's
true or the nanny will know my kids better
than right yeah what are some examples of
star qualities star qualities I think one
of the things that I outline I have a whole
chapter called star power chapter two one
of the examples that I give in the book is
when you think about someone who is a star
like taylor swift or steven spielberg right
so it's not even necessarily a star as in
they're a performer and they're in front of
the camera someone that's a star in their
industry who were they before they had any
credits who was taylor swift before anybody
knew her name she was taylor swift right and
so I think it's about how you show up in the
beginning and I talk about you know like we
all have this greatness within us and you
don't need a resume or an imdb credit or any
other kind of validation to prove that you
can be a star you know that you have greatness
I think that we all have greatness already
within us and so you know star power is about
embracing that connecting to your own star
power that you have before a single person
knows your name or before you have anything
on your resume you can still have that star
power but it's about showing up as a star
now before waiting for somebody else to validate
you and to say that you are a star or to say
that you are greatit's about believing that
in yourself now before you do anything can
you give me example of a star quality that
seems that's kind of unknown that would be
unlikely that you would never think that you
know we think of someone with just amazing
confidence owns a room head turner in so many
wayscharming I think that
for me it's it's not even about necessarily
those things it's a well the confidence piece
it's about the it's about owning your dream
owning what you want and deciding you are
worthy of it because that will translate to
risks that you take in actions you take the
example I give in my book is about steven
spielberg and about his story about how he
you know basically broke in he was able to
get a meeting on the universal studios lot
with chuck silvers who I think was working
in post and he got to connect with him for
three days and he was so excited he got to
be on the lot and I think he got to show him
like a short film he had made or something
like that and chuck said okay well the three
days are up you know I can't get a pass for
you to come back onto the lot you know if
you want to come back you'll have to kind
of find your own way I can't get you like
a permanent pass so Steven Spielberg was like
all right I need to get back on this lot I
need to connect with these people I need to
show them my work I need to get in front of
them so the next day he shows up in a suit
holding a briefcase goes up to the gate and
just waves to the guy at the gate and it looks
like you know he has the appearance of working
there and they just let him in he didn't have
to show a badge that would probably not happen
today because you really do need to have a
drive on today but what I love so much about
that story is that he was taking a risk and
being incredibly bold to try to create opportunity
for himself and he didn't wait until he had
jaws on his resume to feel confident enough
to do that you know he didn't wait until he
was the Steven Spielberg that we know because
I think it's easy for people to go oh he's
Steven Spielberg he can do that but he wasn't
that Steven Spielberg that we know when he
did that so for me it's examples like that
it's like how do you show up in the beginning
do you show up and take bold risks you know
showing up like you are the star now you don't
have to wait until someone else deems you
a star to to take those kinds of risks and
and take those actions I like that so sorry
again it's knowing that start like owning
your dream and saying that I am worthy of
it yes and and when you feel that way what
risks do you end up taking like you know what
I mean I think that a lot of people in Steven
Spielberg's position would never do something
like that until they are at his now known
level of success right somebody won't feel
comfortable taking that big of a risk unless
they already felt validated by Hollywood you
know like one time nothing ever really came
of it but there was some tv show filming near
where I on location near where I lived and
I saw the prop truck and it was open and so
I brought my business cards to the prop truck
and there was no one there and I just left
my business cards on the floor of the prop
truck you know so it's like it's like things
like that it's like how how do you show up
like can you be bold and show up in a way
that most people would never do unless they
already felt validated by the industry that's
a great story yeah I heard about someone else
who had a business card and they were mad
and they were in real estate and they're just
like forget this and they threw them all in
a parking lot and someone found one and said
I have a house to list amazing right yeah
you know look I mean like not every bold risk
is going to be received with open arms but
if you're not taking those risks you're never
going to get the potential opportunities that
could come from them right right because you
know this is a town where you know there's
all these pretty people and and they're accolades
and and people are bragging and and they don't
want to stay small they want to just kind
of like peacock feathers and I think it's
easy to be in a room whatever your thing is
and and hear that from the side and you're
like I i what am I doing here you know and
then but I like what you're saying that if
you just all you have to do is just say I'm
owning this is what I want to do and I'm worthy
of it and it doesn't matter if this person
you know has this beautiful plumage that they're
kind of showing the world my thing is also
going to matter you have the plumage too it's
just not visible yet like I i really believe
that we all have that greatness inside of
us I think it's internal I think you know
the plumage that you're talking about comes
from like external you know IMDB credits or
you know prestige or celebrity or whatever
but to me it's a hundred percent an internal
thing it has nothing to do with the external
and you can have all those external things
and still show up and feel imposter syndrome
you know and not feel worthy of being in the
room that you're in and and that happens you
know all the time too look at you know child
stars you know a lot of times where it doesn't
it doesn't pan out as they get older because
it's like too much too soon they weren't ready
for it mentally right and so maybe they felt
like an imposter or whatever there's a million
different reasons why that happens but it's
like you know 75 of lottery winners end up
getting going broke and again it's like this
whole idea of like they weren't internally
ready for the thing so to me that plumage
that you speak of is really truly internal
and not external.
Question For The Viewers: Is it a good idea
to believe that your success is inevitable?